Uh,
represented her in that case and that's,
that's how we met.
And so,
I mean I had Pam on and we've both worked a lot in deception detection and
interrogation techniques and stuff.
And so just,
and it came right at a time when,
you know Jesse Smollett is in the news about it.
Is he telling the truth or is he not telling the truth?
And in here we have this conversation.
What did you think immediately when you heard that story?
I was very suspicious when I heard this story.
Jamie and I,
we shut that once the cameras are off for Lego these off.
Fuck that guy that he's real,
that nobody does this.
It was just too much like a movie.
Yeah.
Cause a bad movie.
I mean
it's nine below zero and two people are lying and white just in hopes that he
might come by.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
so strange.
Yeah,
it was suspicious and you know,
he's entitled to due process and he's going to get it.
Yeah.
He's going to get it.
And now he's saying,
yes,
I'm a untreated drug problem.
So he's trying to carve out some path to explain his bizarre behavior,
but there are very,
there are very specific lie behaviors that people
can't really control.
Like what kind of stuff?
Well,
for example,
when,
when people are really desperately trying to convince you they're telling the
truth,
they'll do a lot of times what are called convincing statements.
Um,
rather than just telling you what they did or didn't do,
they'll do convincing statements like,
you know
me,
ah,
like somebody saying,
who's who?
Somebody stole the petty cash in the office.
You know,
me,
I give more money.
I donate more money than was stolen yearly.
You guys know me.
I mean
I was employee of the week,
you know,
there this convincing you there's,
there's a nice guy and then
what someone does if the wrongly accused,
no.
What does someone do if they're wrongly accused,
if the wrongly accused,
they'll look you straight up in the eye and tell you I didn't do it.
And if you asked them,
what do you think should happen to somebody that did an innocent person will
say,
I think they should be found.
I think it should be held fully accountable to the extent of the law.
Somebody that's guilty,
we'll say,
well,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean,
people make
mistakes.
I mean,
yeah.
You know,
you get,
yeah,
you got to give a guy a second chance.
Do you worry that in coaching that you're essentially coaching liars by telling
people this kind of stuff and someone who does steal the money,
you know,
would be able to kind of like,
Hey,
uh,
it's not for amateurs.
And,
uh,
and um,
when you,
there were some things that you can tell people to watch for,
but one of the things you do if there's somebody that you suspect is you
increase their cognitive load during the interrogation and there's no way you
can prepare for that.
Oh,
do you do that?
Well,
um,
you plan a mind virus,
for example,
a mind virus.
I like it.
Yeah.
This is a very mason type shit.
I think when he did.
Um,
like if lesson,
some money's missing,
if I said to you,
um,
is there any reason somebody would have told me that they saw you near a cashbox
about the time it went missing?
Dumped down.
Okay.
Now people talk at 125 words a minute.
They think at 12 to 1400 words a minute.
Now,
if it takes you five,
five seconds to tell me no,
you took the money
because if you weren't miss right now,
if you didn't take it,
you know you didn't take it.
You don't need to run scenarios through your head to think who could have seen
me,
Ben.
I mean it was,
I didn't see anybody.
Nobody could have seen me,
what did it.
But if you didn't do it,
it doesn't take you one millisecond to say absolutely not.
Have you ever been wrong before?
When you see someone on television,
you go,
I think that guy's guilty and they're innocent or vice verse.
Oh sure.
Because if,
if you really want to know for sure,
if somebody is guilty or innocent,
you need to invest a lot of time.
You need to get a baseline on what they normally look like,
talk like,
feel like,
um,
and then,
and then knowing that baseline,
you didn't need to compare how they're behaving on TV.
So just walking by the screen and seeing it,
um,
you might see things that would ordinarily be lie behaviors that could just be
part of their personality.
So if you're going to really make a judgment,
uh,
you,
you got to put a lot of time in and figure it out.
And what you should do before you decide you're going to be a human lie detector
is do your homework and y'all tried to figure it out objectively before you
figure it out behaviorally.
I mean,
you ought to do your investigation.
Find out if somebody took the money and you know,
find out where they were and you know,
look for fingerprints and do this and do that.
I mean,
you ought to really objectively figure it out before you rely on these things.
And so unless you get a baseline and get one on one with them and spend a lot of
time,
then you can't be,
you can't be really certain that you know whether they're telling the truth or
whether or not it would be if it was that easy and that some people are pretty
obvious.
Yeah,
I heard a cop once say that when people are guilty they tend to plead and cry
and then when they're not guilty they tend to get angry.
Right.
When they're accused,
people that are wrongly accused are generally,
I write from the beginning till the end.
I mean every case is different,
but if you're wrongly accused,
that person is going to be pissed off from the minute you accused him till the
end because it's like they're self.
Raj is like,
I,
I didn't do this and you're saying I did screw you.
And they don't take a step back.
And when you,
you see people,
they,
they do these convincing statements and they're pleading for you to believe
them.
And then an anytime somebody says now,
in all honesty,
usually the next thing out of their mass ally,
like I said to Joe,
honestly,
as opposed to everything else you've been telling me,
why are we we bracketing this one out is honest.
Or if they invoke the Deity,
oh,
I swear to God,
God as my witness.
And you know,
I don't know whether I have not done what I said you need to do with Jesse
Smollett.
But I do know when he went to the set at Fox,
uh,
he said,
you all know me.
I swear to God I didn't do this.
And I mean there were like three or four of those kinds of statements in like
two or three sentences there.
Well,
my favorite ones is on stage.
He called himself the gay Tupac.
That's enough for me.
That's a little narcissistic.
It's a strange thing though.
Like there was another one today,
a guy lit his house on fire,
I think,
a in Chicago and uh,
said,
uh,
he's a gay fella,
said it was a hate crime and they caught him.
So a lot of that going on,
you know,
a lot of fake crime.
Very strange.
The,
and then sometimes people accuse people of something and someone will say,
why would,
why would someone make something out?
Why would someone turned themselves into a victim?
One think there's a lot of clout and being a victim,
especially today,
there's a lot of,
you get a lot of attention,
a lot of love.
I think there's a lot of false accusations and false attacks and there's a lot
of real ones.
But man,
when the false ones Combo,
it just does a giant disservice to everybody.
Well,
there's a fair amount of research as to why people do these hoaxes and
particularly hate crime hoaxes.
And one of the primary motivation,
of course,
it's sympathy and attention and all that.
But one of the interesting reasons that I've read in research is that they
really feel like it's emblematic of how the system treats them overall.
This is just a dramatic example of it and least they feel like,
I'm treated this
anyhow.
Ah,
so they're just,
yeah,
I'm discriminated against.
I suffer by us.
I'm put down.
This is just a focused example of that.
So I'm really not lying.
I'm just role playing how I'm overall treated.
Oh Wow.
So they justified in their mind if they're just going to bring all this
treatment into one example to bring it into focus.
And so while it's a phony deal,
it really is truthful representation of what their life has really lacked.
They justified
that way.
Oh,
how weird.
You know,
that's,
yeah.
That's a deep psychological shit,
you know?
That's,
uh,
that's stretching.
That's a weird one.
We like you ride it out like that.
Put it in your mind that way.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's,
it's strange too because it gives people this,
um,
this,
it's just this giant public show to watch now,
you know?
And I hate that family.
What a talented young man.
I mean isn't,
I've the Times that I've seen,
I don't want to show a lot,
but the times I've seen him on there singing and assuming it is his voice and
he's singing,
uh,
extremely talented young man,
I find a lot of talented people are fucking crazy.
Well,
you know,
somebody said that somebody said that the really talented singers and actors
were the weird kids from high school that were in drama.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
No,
um,
various levels of crazy,
obviously not all deceptive,
but you know,
some of the most brilliant actors are just completely out of their mind and
that's one of the reasons why they're so good at acting because they can look a,
my friend,
my friend Wayne Fetterman had a bit,
he did about it on stage and he's like,
guess what?
It's not fucking normal to be able to just cry.
Yeah.
He goes,
you could just cry and pretend something's wrong and cries.
I,
that's crazy.
These are crazy people and you really can't go to a certain place.
You've,
you don't have a little of that in you.
My,
my dad used to always say when he's working with patients,
you'd say something about that.
Oh boy,
I can't stand about me.
Cause you say you can't see it in them if you don't have a little evidence on
you.
There's some truth there.
Oh,
there's a hundred percent truth and that,
that is the thing that drives me the craziest about weak people.
I'm so terrified of seeing weakness and just,
just,
just being pathetic.
I'm so terrified to seeing that in myself.
I see it in other people and it just,
it smells.
I smelled like a drug sniffing dog.
Like,
oh,
there it is.
Yeah.
You smell desperation.